[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
michelle tafoya nbc sunday night
football
nbc wednesday afternoon football
sideline reporter
and uh she joins us now from pittsburgh
how confident are you we're playing
football today michelle
i'm very confident but first i have to
say jalen suggs of gonzaga
don't ignore him okay mini guy point
guard
all right um yeah we're gonna have some
football it's the thanksgiving edition
of sunday night football on wednesday
afternoon that's what we have
uh we feel pretty confident look the
steelers um have two guys missing
and james connor and stephon tuitt
the ravens you should see this flip card
if people don't know what a flip card is
it's the card that they give the media
to it
lists all the starters in the second and
third deep it is a mess
it's just an absolute mess for the
ravens but um
you know some of these guys are coming
back the rumors that mark ingram and j.k
dobbins will play in this game are false
they will not they're not coming
and so uh but you know they're going to
take rapid tests before they leave the
hotel today and assuming everyone clears
we've got a football game
okay could there be a number like is
there a number of positive tests that
could happen this morning
where that it would put this game in
jeopardy well my guess would be
again this is not official dan but what
they've been doing is i mean if there's
a single test
then really if that person's been in
meals in a walk-through in a meeting
then everyone's at risk um or or they
could say you know what it's a
it's a defensive back we're only worried
about the corners and everyone else is
is negative i'm sure it would have to be
cleared with the league um but yeah
that's something i'm sure
john harbaugh is grinding his teeth
about this morning is
get these tests back and please make
them negative how has your role changed
in the last week
in in approaching this game i've just
become
very familiar with pittsburgh dan um
especially the downtown
area it's been you know i you know
the role hasn't changed so much although
i'll tell you
we're all kind of like dizzy of
looking through the numbers and the
names okay this guy now is off the list
but this guy's on
so they have how many starters missing
and how many of those guys are pro
bowlers and which
who's oh but this guy now is back and
this guy's off
that part has been honestly the most
time-consuming part of this
for me anyway and and i think really for
all of us trying to figure out who's
playing
uh you know all these practice squad
players that are coming up i mean it's
just a bunch of them
and people don't know who they are so
preparing that way
i know it's been tough for chris getting
these names of guys you never heard of
and um you know for me yeah i just feel
like i'm a i'm a counter i'm a
i i count covid test that's what i've
done all week
we're talking to michelle tafoya nbc
sunday night football sideline reporter
mike tarico chris collinsworth and
michelle will be on the call
the game starts at 3 40 eastern what is
the schedule this morning
for these uh two teams or when did they
take the field
uh okay so kickoffs at 3 40. we go on
the air at 3 30.
um i think the teams arrive in the one
o'clock
hour uh you know as i talked to cam
hayward last night i said what's the day
like tomorrow he goes it's just a
delayed one o'clock game
that's the way they're looking at it
they're looking at like you know what
we're supposed to play at one
but there's a lot of snow so we got to
play at 3 30 instead
so i think you know everything's just
bumped a little bit um
i know these guys are itching to get out
there
the one kind of silver lining especially
for pittsburgh is
guys have had all this time to rest and
get better they were
they were pretty beat up and they've
gotten to to rest and get better
i would say that's true for some of the
ravens as well but
um you know pittsburgh feels great
now harbaugh loves the idea that no one
thinks they can win this game
but it is hard to see them putting
together a team that can
contend with with what the steelers have
going right now though the first game
was very close
did you talk to roethlisberger did the
crew talk to roethlisberger
yes okay uh what what did you take away
from
that interview um
nothing particularly groundbreaking um
you know just
i i think the usual stuff uh he feels
great
um loves his team they don't need to go
undefeated
they just want to keep winning their
ultimate goal as a super bowl obviously
and they're really confident
there's no drama with pittsburgh and
right yeah
yeah not really isn't that funny and so
many times that there
are but uh you know it's it's
interesting no drama uh tomlin's his
usual
brilliant self with all these lines that
come out of his mouth that just
just kill you um but it's yeah there's
not a lot of drama because there isn't a
lot of
injury now the interesting thing about
james connor their running back their
their superstar is that
you know he's a cancer survivor and one
of the things about this cohort thing is
if you have a secondary
you know a comorbidity they call it that
can be dangerous but james has been
healthy for a long time and as far as we
know he's
he's handling this just fine and i would
say the same thing about mark andrews
for the ravens he's a
type one diabetes guy and having a great
season by the way but
you know he came into this season i was
wide open and didn't really think
anything of it but those are the two i
think
on on these two teams that you have to
kind of just have a little bit of extra
concern for
what role does weather play today not as
much as it would have last night because
yesterday was a complete snowstorm here
and things were very slick and they got
it went from snow to rain late in the
day it was ugly
so i i think weather is going to be a
non-factor it's supposed to be sunny
cold um but you know if
if anything was going to be impacted i
would say it's the kicking game but that
has never seemed to bother justin tucker
what's interesting justin tucker is like
the most successful kicker at heinz
ever maybe he's missed one kick here one
field goal attempt and that was in his
rook
his first season the interesting thing
is for him
is his long snapper morgan cox is out
with kovid
so they've got a practice guy coming up
to to do the long snapping with this
group
justin tucker their punter sam cook who
does the holding
and this group has played 90 straight
games together
and now they're interrupting this and uh
we'll see how that goes you know
justin didn't want to talk about he's a
little superstitious he told me
the guy nick's gonna do great nick moore
who's coming up
but you know that could be sort of a an
interesting twist in all this a guy
who has had just ridiculous success
at heinz in justin tucker is that
messed up today who knows you're also
hosting uh
nbc sports uncovered a podcast and uh
the
latest interview is with john gruden
what did we
unearth from the podcast with the new
and improved 2.0 john gruden
for me the most interesting thing was
how emotional he can still get
about thinking about when he was traded
to tampa
that when he was when the the raiders
were able to say yeah we don't
we don't really need you anymore we're
going to trade you it really
i was surprised at how much that still
stings
for him even though he went to tampa
and beat the raiders in the super bowl
and really had the ultimate revenge
um but it's still it still is hard for
him to talk about and that that was
interesting to me because as hard as i
tried to get more information from him
he would say uh it's too painful and it
makes me emotional and so i'm done
talking about that
but given what happened in that super
bowl it it felt like they knew every
play that rich gannon was calling did
does gruden admit that now that they
knew exactly what was going on
he he in a way
yeah i mean they they acknowledge the
fact that that was one of those years
where you didn't have that
that weak break between the end of the
season and the super bowl or between the
end of the playoffs and the super bowl
that we have now that sort of bye week
and that really didn't allow
the raiders to change much and so yeah
that with that short weekend notice
uh or short week of practice in
preparation they weren't able to change
much and yeah
gruden gruden knew a lot and gruden
loves to have some colorful language
um in practice on the sidelines
if you were going to like was there a
moment where you went oh my god you're
on the sidelines and you hear
a coach go off have you had one of those
moments
with gruden well anybody just where the
language was a little more colorful than
uh
you would have thought sure i have it
you know what's odd about my my
strongest memory of gruden
was early in my my sidelining career
i was still at cbs and it was the day
after christmas and we were doing a game
at oakland i don't even remember who the
other team was because
on christmas night the night before the
game i had a surprise in that my my
then boyfriend now husband popped the
question
on christmas night so uh i went out the
next day to that game just you know like
on a cloud
um and lance barrow was the the producer
of the game who kept saying
michelle hold the microphone in your
left hand so everyone could see the ring
and um and so then i just remember at
half time i was
waiting for gruden to come out and
gruden sort of pointed to the ground
like
you come over here i'm not coming to you
and so i went over and talked to him but
you know i have a great relationship
with gruden because we worked on monday
night football on espn for a couple
years together and
uh but yeah i mean every coach is
different and they're all they've all
got their thing and some guys are really
much more polite than you would expect
and some guys are really salty
who's really polite um
you know it's funny dan it doesn't come
to mind right away
how does belichick is he ever like
expressive with you effusive
where he just i i wouldn't say effusive
i'm not sure that he's
ever really effusive unless he's talking
about a great story
or something historical in football but
you know he
look i'm appreciative of any coach
that's willing under those circumstances
to talk to you i do have a a memory of
him going into that last super bowl we
covered
in arizona and i remember they were
heading into the locker room for the
last time before kickoff and i
caught up with him and i said let me
just ask you do you get nervous
before these big games and he goes yeah
i do
and i thought that was interesting
because he's a guy that would never
really let on that things you know
bother him in that or
that he's anything but just feet on the
ground and everything
so i thought that was really interesting
um you know it's
it's a game to game thing dan and you
just kind of go into each interview with
these coaches whether they're winning or
losing just
bracing for the worst and trying not to
ask a stupid question
have fun today michelle and uh hopefully
you get to uh
escape pittsburgh not that it's not a
great city but you've probably spent
more time there than you you're
you're paying taxes in pittsburgh we are
we all are
um and there's no room service so but no
we're good
i don't want to sound like we're
complaining we're not we're it's all
good and we're excited but thank you dan
for having me
thank you michelle that's uh michelle
tafoya nbc
sunday night football now wednesday
afternoon football sideline reporter
festivities start at 3 30 eastern on nbc
and also
the nbc podcast with john gruden
sports uncovered with michelle tafoya